- Let's roast!
[bell dinging]
- Keith only uses
lambskin condoms
because after sex,
he enjoys a snack.
[laughter]
- Anna's just jealous because
my body is shaped like the eggs
she can no longer produce.
[laughter]
- Keith just thinks I'm old
'cause I'm four years past
his life expectancy.
[laughter]
- Wow.
- Look, I don't want to say
Anna's desperate for love,
but I did see her standing
in front of a Home Depot
wearing a wedding dress.
[laughter]
- Keith told me
he has a really big dick,
which makes sense;
the average blue whale penis
is eight to ten feet.
[laughter]
- Anna has a long face,
buck teeth,
and she once fucked
a married man.
What I'm saying is...
♪ She's a horse
that caused divorce ♪
♪ With no remorse,
of course, of course ♪
- Last joke.
Last joke.
- Keith's a fat bisexual,
so you could fuck his neck,
his back,
his pussy,
and his crack.
[laughter]
- That's absolutely true.
I--I go both ways,
just like Anna's
shitty tits.
Now...
[laughter]
Honestly, I think Anna's
just jealous
because my parents get to watch
the battle on TV,
and hers have to watch from
wherever Mexicans go
instead of Heaven.
[laughter]
[helicopter blades whirring]
- Run, Willie, run!
[bell dinging]
- Oh, my God.
- D'Elia looks in shock.
- Really tough, man.
- Are you okay?
- That's really tough.
I mean, that--
those were both great.
[laughter]
- Oh, my...
- Wait, Jeremiah,
let me get one of those.
- Milk man!
- Thank you.
- Milk man.
- [chanting] Chug! Chug! Chug!
- No cookies?
This is definitely the weirdest
show on television.
Gotta vote.
- Who you like, World Peace?
- I think the--
When he said her boobs
went different directions...
[laughter]
I think that was false.
She has great boobs.
So, um...
- Oh!
- Hey, no, wait. I got--
- Good boobs!
- You know you're in the NBA,
right?
There's so many more boobs
for you.
- No, man.
[laughter]
- Security,
we have a horny NBA player
in the building right now.
- Oh, I'm super horny.
- Lock your daughters up.
- It was a tie,
and then since you
had a false statement,
I'll give it to Anna.
- Hey!
That's good judging.
- I'm gonna give it to you
because of your--you're just--
nothing fazed you.
You just rolled with everything.
There was not a--
no twitchy face, you just--
- He has Tourette's.
You're lying. [laughs]
- I twitch because
I keep looking at you,
and my eyeballs try
to kill themselves, like--
- Can we wrap this up
so she can get back to looking
for the six-fingered man
who killed her father?
[laughter]
- It's that prince, though.
- Saudi Prince.
- That's that prince, though.
- [ululating]
- I enjoyed both of you.
I think you guys were fantastic.
I'm just gonna give it to Anna
because she--
for me, after her jokes,
what I like she did,
she did this little--
- She had style.
She had style.
- And that did it for me,
so I give it to Anna.
- That's a very
Sebastian-like move.
- I was gonna say.
I learned it from watching you.
- It's two-one, Keith.
Jeff, who do you like?
- I don't think
that there's any doubt.
That lambskin condoms joke
won it for me, Anna.
Keith, you're a true competitor.
You've been doing--
you've done, what, 19 battles?
- Yeah.
- Jesus. Wow.
- That's amazing.
Uh, you're a killer,
but I gotta say,
I really think
this was Anna's night.
So congratulations, darling.
You got it.
- Make it loud for Anna!
Hug each other.
- Aside from the part
that I didn't win,
it went exactly how
I wanted it to go tonight.
- Exactly.
- She came hard.
Nothing fazed her.
It was perfect.
- I love you
and I'm gonna be fertile
for the next 20 years.
- Eat shit and die.
- [laughs]
- No, I love you.
You did so great.
You made me
very, very proud.
- Aw!
- I'm glad you're my friend.